hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my legends of tomorrow episode 12
video just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet the whole whole
conceit was them meeting their younger
selves you could kind of tell some of
the beats that they were going for like
they wanted to take the opportunity to
show young Quentin Lance like haha he
has hair again he doesn't know about any
of the Green Arrow craziness that's
gonna be happening in a couple years
heat wave gets the same moment with his
younger self the Captain Cold got in an
earlier episode like hey listen kid take
care of yourself I feel like the actors
are actually doing a much greater job
with some of these emotional beats but
some of the emotional moments are still
a little unearned like we didn't know
anything about Jax's dad dying till the
beginning of the episode we probably
should have learned about that a long
time ago so let's do top five WTF and
I'll talk about comic book Easter eggs
as we go along
so number five come with me if you want
to live they grab young heatwave with a
nice terminator reference I think
heatwave ended up being the funniest
character in this episode so much i
winking to his younger self you sure you
want to leave your younger self in there
with young me so actually number four
WTF younger Quentin Lance in Starling
city so this is right before the Queen's
Gambit goes down so there's like a
douchebag
Oliver wig running around somewhere
causing all kinds of trouble sleeping
with Sarah behind laurels bags all that
awesomeness is getting ready to happen
but the funniest Sara moment though was
when she went in to stop the fight
between her younger self and heatwaves
young self next time you slap em use an
open palm and she's not your type most
of you probably caught that but if you
didn't catch that joke it's just because
that version of Sara had not realized
that she was a lesbian and she hadn't
really come to terms with that yet and
if you want to be specific you could say
she's bisexual but yeah now your type
buddy number three WTF meet young rip
hunter stabby street-urchin so what he
meant by that is that he just grew up on
the streets I don't know if they're ever
gonna address the idea that he's the son
of Booster Gold usually the TV shows are
pretty true to the characters
backstories from the comics even if they
can't do certain characters that are big
parts of that like I wouldn't be
surprised that the TV show wasn't able
to do Booster Gold
I mean I'm gonna cross my fingers and
hope that they do at some point but in
the comics rip hunters dad is Booster
Gold so even though they've trimmed a
little bit of his backstory they're
actually still pretty true to the comics
like they haven't trampled over Booster
Gold yet but they kind of use that to
explain how the time masters recruit
people they just
pick them from across space and time
which is why I think the pilgrim is not
a character from the comics number two
WTF meet the pilgrim so pilgrim is a
character from the Wildstorm universe
which technically got folded into the
main DC cannon after flashpoint but the
problem is is this episode does nothing
to reference anything about her
backstory only that she is called
pilgrim which is why I think the Time
Master just kind of plucked her from the
time of the pilgrims and that's why they
call her pilgrim because she was born a
pilgrim so if it wasn't clear the time
masters recruit from all over time and
space they find someone that has the
skills that they want and as long as it
won't derp the time line
they'll just pluck them and put them in
the time masters Academy the orphanage
where young rip hunter is staying where
they stash all the kids is a creation of
the time masters but it's also hidden in
time so the time masters themselves
can't find it it's kind of like a
temporal safety deposit box but number
one WTF is the team versus the pilgrim
so you kind of tell they visually they
wanted to get to this moment in the
episode so that's why they tease the
pilgrims abilities earlier in the
episode you know where she can locally
stop time like she has tactile control
over time within a certain small sphere
around herself so that's why she keeps
spinning around here but it was a funny
moment my god you thought I was a little
kid but I'm gonna stab the out of
you let me know what your favorite
moment from the episode was I mean there
were some nice emotional moments like
heatwave had with his younger son like
look dude do not turn into me where you
had that funny moment with Quentin where
it's like oh yeah I'm totally helping
people and I'm just gonna casually not
tell you about all the craziness that's
gonna be happening to you in a couple
years you're gonna lose your hair you're
gonna run around the city for a couple
years chasing down the vigilante only to
find out that he's Oliver Queen and both
of your daughters are gonna die one of
them more than once even if you haven't
been watching arrow for the last couple
years it was still a funny moment but
you get the idea like it helps if you
watch arrow in the flash because these
personal moments just wind up being so
much funnier so there's ever a case to
be made for watching all three shows
then this would be in like a lot of the
Easter eggs they have or comic book
Easter eggs because they're comic book
TV shows but a lot of the references and
jokes are also internal to the series
like they'll be making a joke about
something that happened a couple years
ago on arrow like the Queen's Gambit and
Lee Anne you you wouldn't know about
that if you didn't watch arrow so the
big news
is that next week on legends of tomorrow
we're gonna meet vandal savages daughter
in the comics he has two daughters I
think the TV show is just combining them
into a single character and if you
haven't been reading the Superman comics
lately like just this year they did this
big Vandal Savage storyline that
involved a bunch of his children so
there was this big arc where he steals
Superman's powers he tries to use the
meteor that originally gave him his
powers and his immortality to
supercharge himself but that was all
leading up into like a big rebirth
reboot so like right now they've just
rebooted the Superman comics so it's a
little confusing if you try to pick it
up cold turkey but it's just nice that
they're doing Vandal Savage on legends
of tomorrow and they just used them in a
big comic book storyline with Superman
so the big news is this weekend Game of
Thrones is starting there's a bunch of
other stuff happening so I'm gonna be
doing a couple extra videos on Saturday
just to get ready I've got some more
Doctor Strange I'm working on a game of
Thrones refresher video for season six
just for all the important stuff you
need to know so be sure to subscribe to
get that that's probably gonna be the
first video that I post tomorrow while
you guys wait for me to post that I did
a big zoom explainer for the flash I
know it was really confusing this week
you can click here to learn all about
that and you can click here for my
Gotham Azrael trailer video they just
introduced the Azrael character from the
comics so pretty big deal thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight